when you really think about it like the
most genius people of our time right
type one of them is delivery boy Wow
that's Jeff Bezos Wow dad yeah Bezos
sucks by the way to hire more Mexicans
than he's a genius because of it Elon
Musk what do you do drilled into the
ground just sent [ __ ] to outer
space we've been doing that since the
80s out where have you been we haven't
done you say we did that [ __ ] before the
80s bra hole up when did we go for the
first time we did that [ __ ] before color
TV would we went to space in the sixties
dawg yeah oh it's hot what yeah shocking
I know
there's no way yes 1960 bro get out of
here bro so what did he do moon landing
was 1969
that's crazy we like the space in the
same uniform black people got rights
right 68 or 63 or some [ __ ]
okay so civil rights bill 67 one of them
shitty moon is 61
that's 169 you said 69 was the moon you
said I was a moon one was outer space
yeah we gave rights once we're like we
get the South African space program
should be all the best yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying like I don't
know what they really did like so he
just made a rocket that comes back the
exact same place you know speaking of
refurbished he made the refurbish rocket
that's on its higher I'm not going on no
refurbished rocket dude you thank you
are you going on a refurbish rocket yeah
I trust anything
Oh hanging off yet come on yo you want
once you use it a little bit the screws
come on hey fun about the depreciation
of the rocket that's the only thing I'm
giving a [ __ ] about all right no no I
didn't know that [ __ ] is going you don't
even buy vintage clothes like there's no
way I'm gonna go on a vintage rocket
yeah you oh are you saying I do buy
vintage clothes I'll go and you I'm
saying you won't even buy [ __ ] oh I
thought you were like I'm about that
vintage life this is not trust me I know
this rocket has successfully gone oh
whoa no [ __ ] age rocket it's not
whiskey five years
it's barely used so what gently you know
I must mint condition I'll do refurbish
hi Brooke live [ __ ] virgin air you
cook yeah I'm gonna virgin hair I'm a
wave and if your ship blows up i'ma see
you should come apart imagine when you
get sneakers like they're not good until
you break them in a little bit that's
just a broken intro creases on my
[ __ ] box yeah
no no you don't want a nice and snug
what is e la makin I gotta have a sit
down in LA what did he make he made a
rocket that comes back yes yeah he's the
first private company he's gonna make
solar electric mate don't give that
credit to he made the best he make the
best one okay he made the best version
show some [ __ ] already exists he made a
rocky that comes back boom okay I think
what'd he do he low-key limeade PayPal
then he made PayPal PayPal that's how
you pay for everything online when your
girl buys you thank you see I know what
it is but really what is it
it's just credit card borrow an Internet
[Music]
we act like this is the most crazy ping
Berlin it's [ __ ] crazy
and outer space I've never thought of
that you
it's not a wish is all one-way Oh y'all
gonna try to pay your friend back like
man I wish I could do this on Internet
bro all crazy yeah we could yes we could
we couldn't before
now you crazy [ __ ] is dumb name one
person that's actually an innovator that
actually done some side you put cliffs
innovation that's change turn your phone
to the side dude you know I must gay
people auto-drive so they can watch your
YouTube clips more that was watching oh
he was driving watching it now going
every person that I've finished it
Albert Einstein what did he do equals MC
square is this some stuffs relative
sometimes yeah first of all he would
know at some point yo son that's all he
was he was genius enough to justify
incest so who's a genius then who's a
genius yeah I yeah I know real genius is
this yeah
someone that really changed the game
some who literally change the game is
never the same innovator innovator you
really are you ready for it yeah Ghandi
bruh
[Applause]